In summary, what have we learned from our friend the zebra?
Well, we learned that we took our approach of making a concept inventory
and then refining the ideas and choosing the simplest implementation we could think of
and then doing a back of an envelop calculation to say how long is it going to take
to run this simple implementation and then refining the code as necessary,
making it a little bit faster by swapping around some of the clauses.
We also learned the idea of building tools.
We built tools for timing and counts.
In general we learned this idea of separation of aspects from the program
to try to keep the design as clean as possible,
so that you could tell what was working on getting the problem right
and what was working on making it more efficient.
In the end you might say, wow, that was a clever solution.
It was great to see how it works out,
but we can see if we just follow the steps
we can arrive at a solution like that every time.